dafür aufstehen ganz ganz viel lernen
sendetermin mit handwerkern und barren
musste ich war noch nie mein name ist
luca letztlich will kommen heute zu
einem neuen video gezeigten video
geschickte niemand ein interview mit mir
geführt hat bei dem ich aber gar nicht
dabei war
also da reagiere ich jetzt drauf
[Applaus]
alphakanal deutschland welcher kanal
betreibern endlich der dümmste kanal
deutschlands
jetzt ist mein titel habe ich ja mal
wieder eine chance bekommen jemanden für
und auf jungen diesmal ist es auch
niemand geringeres als die bekräftigung
lukas video geschickt hat habe ich
wirklich gedacht ok dazu defekte
interview was ich vor ein paar tagen bei
dem fans have been dinge geben habe und
mit der erwartung mich dann auch das
video rein gegangen aber ich würde sagen
wir schauen dass wir weiter und da würde
ich sagen lägen jedoch schon glatt mit
dem interview ich habe ihnen jede menge
fragen zu dem treasury und legal
gestellt und der zeitpunkt wo er
wirklich meinte fragenden 300 in ihrer
zelle und mir vorgestellt dass ich so
was bleibt am besten fragen kunden für
eine ganz wichtige sache okay du dich
ich bleibe dran ich hoffe wieder lustige
dach oder digitalem empfang direkt mit
dem interview kannst super vorstellungen
danke luca an der stelle hat sie mal
wieder super hingekriegt und ich würde
sagen fangstopp plattner an mit der
ersten frage an dich was gefällt dir am
meisten auf youtube möchtest du uns das
sagen bis juni um weil sie noch nicht so
ganz verstanden habt einen youtube kanal
der quasi interviews mit youtube wird
die gar keine wirkliche interview
gewinnen sondern den übrigen welche
ausschnitte aus den videos bestimmte
sich über und schneidet die für seine
antworten passen da rein
also das ist ein fake interview aber ich
würde sagen mehr reagieren mal langsam
weiter darauf mittagessen zwischen ok
anzugehen mit der menge mit unserer
ersten ganzen schritt immer okay dachte
ich mir doch schon alles nur lauten
herrn alpha gewinn gehe ich nur der
menge mit und feiert
ist auch nur die wahrheit
nichtsdestotrotz werde ich dir gerne
noch ein paar weitere fragen stellen
lieber luca erstmal ein paar persönliche
sachen aus session an kommst du
eigentlich aus daher kommt der luke also
vor allem selbst wenn es ein
realistisches interview gewesen seien
leute die es gewesen wären aber ich bin
wieder fit ist kann ich überhaupt nötig
wenn es hätte sein sollen ich meine du
redest du die ganze zeit fragt mich auch
gleich im land kommen und vor allem im
ausland
woher denn aus dem ausland das natürlich
schön ist also außer ankommen
möchtest du noch verraten aus welchem
land du da jetzt wirklich kommt langsam
also kannst du doch nicht aus dem
ausland
deutschland
ich komme aus dem ausland also aus
ich merke schon dass wir nicht alle
herzlich gern am himmel bild ein paar
jobs teilt aber dass auch gleich eine
ganz gute überleitung weil ich habe
jetzt mal eine frage an dich und zwar
warum bist du nicht der held weil ich
einen computer einen content machen das
merkte auch daran dass sich
beispielsweise eigentlich nie mit
anderen youtube operiere ich bin also
lasst ihn nicht er hält bisher nach
himmelweit youtube meinen content mache
und nicht mit anderen leuten kooperieren
also wenn ich lüge sein will muss sich
mit mehr leuten corp richtig fit ist
macht überhaupt keinen sinn digger du
hattest doch mal erwähnen das ist schon
ein dreier hatte wo endeavour dann nein
gesagt ich habe in der tat vor einiger
zeit ein video hochgeladen wohl etwas
perverse fragen die gestellt bekommen
habe beantwortet haben und da ging es
auch um 3 und da habe ich aber gesagt
nein ich hatte noch nie ein dreier
also das ist jetzt mittlerweile nicht
nur ein fake interview sondern auch noch
mit fragen aber damit das ganze hier
weiterhin sinn macht würde ich sagen
okay wir potenten mal als wert passiert
möchte sie uns verraten mit wem das
eigentlich war
mehr hallo und hier mit mikro in der
hand
ich wollte wenigstens vernünftige leute
gewesen und wie war das duo hat euch
dreien hin zu gefallen natürlich ob das
freut mich auf jeden fall und so soll es
ja eigentlich auch sein bei einem dreier
die gruppiert so die beiden in seinem
sozialen umfeld über dateien kann zur
installation ungefähr sagen wir sind
irgendwie einer gewissen form eine
familie eine gemeinschaft
und wehe
das ist so wie wenn feuer wasser und
erde sagt worden wie nach dem ersten mal
mit micr partner beziehungsweise wann
hast du ihn das erste mal getroffen
kannst du uns da genauso sagen tableau
glaube ich einfach nach auf party
gewesen okay also was hast du denn als
anmachspruch zu mir ehrlich gesagt nicht
was er dir eigentlich so geschockt ich
denke dass auf jeden fall wirklich die
beste unterhaltung vor allem mit dem
bett ein anspruch auf je gehört habe
meine leute stellt euch das war einfach
vor ihr gehe zu leuten hin und das mädel
oder wenn ihr medium jungen hin so ganz
gut findet und das an was positiv
entgegen weil keiner sache erledigt ich
nicht
normale kommunikation okay aber als
anderswo wäre schon harter corp okay das
ist ein schock für mich der tief
natürlich recht unterste liga ja ja ich
noch leute an die an die guten alten
zeiten damit auf der haut party alp
damit wie diablo geredet habe erfahrung
mit wirklich war
ja
jetzt wasserdichte am liebsten gegen
michael in dieser situation gemacht ich
meine dass wir wirklich nicht jetzt
einen disstrack einen disstrack
ich
als rap technisch und musikalisch
begabter youtube abonnent ist raus gegen
jemanden der das noch weniger kann als
ich
schlechte idee was hast du in dem moment
gedacht als er drei dann irgendwann
vorher hatte dass menschen all das
natürlich verständlich bei ihm zwei
pappnasen
also die beiden nicht findest du
eigentlich so meinen canal du hast ja
noch nicht mal gesagt wie bist du denn
eigentlich wirklich mensch der welt sein
da kann es überhaupt nicht beurteilen
aber über den content kann und darf ich
urteile bin ich einfach total bescheuert
also ich bin nicht viel
das ist ich weiß nicht was sie dabei
denkt über hochgeladen
das weiß aber nicht was sehr sehr lieb
von dir erzählt mal ehrlich haben viele
video von mir gegeben hat er in über
youtube kanal was habe ich nur das eine
video gewinnen was interview von mir
aber da bin ich ehrlich gesagt ganz cool
und ich finde dass in einen kanal
konzepten bekannte mit mega gut klick
beten to beispiel hier das interview mit
mir einfach luca spricht oder seine
erste beziehung
ja
und es geht um irgend so ein fake mit
miguel pablo und keine ahnung was
möchtest du zu deinen zuschauer nur
etwas sagen zum abschluss was ist eure
lieblings so da war es auch schon wieder
mit dem interview vom kongress am
abschluss auf jeden fall zu ende des
interviews ich kann sagen das video hat
mir gefallen hat mich unterhalten und
ich bin den konten eigentlich ganz cool
natürlich solltest du also das ist halt
vorprogrammiert bei solchen sachen aber
ich bin eigentlich ganz cool gemacht
also ihr findet sie die ohne der
beschreibung verlinkt ich hatte heute
sehr sehr wenig zeit für ein video ich
habe auch schon bei twitter
gewerkschafter eigentlichkeit bekommen
sollte ein tag bestand heute auf der
früher aufstehen ganz ganz viel lernen
handwerkern online gegangen aber ich
hoffe es hat euch trotzdem gefallen
getan hat erst mal lecker schaffen wir
raum bleibt
eigentlich müsste das hinkriegen oder
den fahrer von weggeschafft als 60.000
gleichen nächsten video buster packung
und nochmal ganz gut zu einer anderen
sache die man am herzen liegt mir
gestern die letzten block von der
hinreise hochgeladen und waren wieder
viele positive resonanzen darunter am
staat und volk viele leute von euch
alles gleich und folgte feiern ja auch
die villa von glock ich wollte jetzt
aber nicht am ende von dem einen blog
noch so zehn weitere minuten darüber
reden sollen deswegen mache ich das
jetzt eben ganz schnell neben dem ganzen
positiven feedback habe ich auch
feedback bekommen von wegen die sind ja
gar nicht so stark beschnitten oder er
von dem anderen youtube blogger xy dass
die kühle aus aber leute ich finde also
wenn man sich geile landschaftsaufnahmen
angucken will dann kann man das
natürlich bei den ganzen unz igen dokus
offenlegt und bei itunes etc machen
bevor ich jetzt voll ausschöpfen werde
ich möchte einfach dass meinen blog wenn
ich demnächst noch mehr druck machen
wäre und ich denke ich werde dann zu
machen dass ich wenn ab und zu ganz
cooles papier das ja einfach mal die
kamera mitnehmen um kontakte aber ich
möchte einfach wirklich meinen blog
dadurch ausgleichen dass ihr bescheuert
sind also lustig dumm bescheuert und
nicht dass die sich dadurch auszeichnen
wie viel geld und wie viel teures kamera
equipment habe und die tolle aufnahmen
ich bedrohen hinkriege oder so also gar
keine frage ich feierte mega mir andere
dort anzuknüpfen wo ultra keine
landschaften und co aber ich selber kann
das einfach nicht zu meinem kanal meinem
konto bin und ich glaube ihm merkt auch
wenn ihr dafür die at gewinner dass ich
mit meinem ganzen kanal und meiner figur
selbst er selbstironisch unsere ein
bisschen dumm umgehen also ich hoffe das
nicht versteht was ich damit bezwecken
block und damit auch vor allem jetzt
nicht ein date locker werde sondern
weiterhin hier mein content mache und
ich glaube die klage erst noch geboren
und wer wie viel zu tun und der wirklich
stress aber an irgendwas passiert werde
ich dann wieder die kamera mitnehmen und
zum blog machen und zu der zweiten bzw
dritten ganz kurze sache noch schneller
vettel hofft dass am ersten juni die
sommerkollektion in meinem job lounge
deswegen steht hier oben gerade
wahrscheinlich auch im werbevideo
eingeblendet war hey wir leben in
deutschland alles muss strikt geregelt
sein
zu diesem job lounge bekomme ich
dahingehend hat sehr viele fragen von
wegen was ist denn überhaupt gelaunt
werden die täter damit er noch die luft
unter anderem kommen und jahr das
einzige produkt hat ihre erkenntnis die
luft knapp wird kommen beim ersten
wechsel preise werdet ihr dann wenn am
ersten sechs
das ist mir selber noch nicht ganz so
wie wir kalkulieren und zu den produkten
das sage ich denke ich wieder so ein
zwei wochen vorher dazu gehört und ihr
findet wird hier einen smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf könnt ihr
kostenlos meinen kanal abonnieren er
verfasste keine videos mehr und es ist
cool
also klickt auf den schmalen abonniert
nicht auf und findet ihr auch meinen
shop eingeblendet und hier unten ist ein
anderes video verlinkt zur couch ergraut